[Music]
welcome to mega city
where every day is an adventure wow
but i've never heard of that word
you've never heard of an adventure oh hi
doug everyone wave hi to doug hello
sorry doug i forgot as a robot you're
not as familiar with life in mega city i
think we can help you great idea
everybody should we help doug yes okay
so doug
an adventure is sort of a fun journey
you take like walking through your town
or maybe going hiking hiking never heard
of it well doug why don't you unplug and
try it out does this mean we're going on
a hike today i think it's time for some
good old-fashioned robot father robot
son robot bonding
and that's just one example say you and
your friend emma wanted to go to the
beach beach i don't know that word
you'll love the beach there's so much to
do and discover let's go matey
[Music]
wow you found some great treasures they
could belong in a museum oh
uh multi museum there's only one way to
find out no trip to the museum is
complete without exploring an early
machines exhibit whoa all you have to do
is pull on this rope and you'll lift
something really heavy now i'm lifting
me emma uncle forkrick and
who are you i'm gary and gary when
you're all done you can ride your bike
home i have a big question
why do humans ride bikes to get that
thrill when rubber meets the road when
rubber meets the you know what you'll
just have to learn to ride a bike and
see for yourself great idea emma now get
out there and explore because the more
questions you ask the more adventures
you'll discover i can tell you're
excited about this adventure idea
adventures look amazing unplugged and
foamy
dug unplugs i learned how to have fun
let's somersault enjoy
[Music]